Now we are ready to create deployments,
one for each service.
Front in, auth, and hello.
Then will defy internal services for
the off and hello deployments.
And an external service for
the front in deployment.
Let's examine the off
deployment configuration file.
The first thing I'm going to do is
specify the number of replicas.
This deployment can be used to scale
pods by changing the replica count
in our manifest.
Moving on, you can see the labels that
will be attached to the off pods.
A little further down you'll see we're
using Version 1.0 of the off container.
Use the kubectl create command
to create the off deployment.
As with any other kubernetes object,
we can use to describe command
to see more information
about the off deployment.
Okay, it's now time to create
a service for off deployment.
You've already seen service manifest
files, so I won't go into details here.
Use the kubectl create command
to create the off service.
Now, I'm going to do the same thing to
create and expose the hello deployment.
I wanted to repeat these steps one more
time for the front end deployment.
We'll also need to configure engine X
like we did in the previous tutorial.
Now we are ready to interact with
the front in by grabbing this external
IP address.
And using curl to hit it.
Congratulations, you've deployed
the multi-service application using
kubernetes.
The skills you've learned here will
allow you to deploy complex applications
on kubernetes using a collection
of deployments and services.